unesco-biosphärenreservat Pfälzerwald
eines der größten zusammenhängenden
Waldgebiete Europas
ausgerechnet durch dieses artenreiche
Ökosystem verläuft die Bundesstraße 10
und wenn es nach dem Willen von
Verkehrsminister Wissing geht sollen sie
sogar noch ausgebaut werden dagegen
kämpfen Aktivistinnen von Bund und
Fridays for future seit Jahren gemeinsam
Geld als zerstört den Wald heterweise es
wird Beton Asphalt in die Landschaft
gekippt hier teilweise müssen ganze
Berghänge abgetragen werden also es ist
ein riesen Aufwand natürlich dann auch
eine entsprechend großer CO2-Ausstoß und
für uns ist es nicht einsichtlich weil
natürlich südlich vom Gebiet gibt es
schon Autobahnen warum lenkt man den
Verkehr in die dorthin außerdem verläuft
parallel zur B10 eine Schienenstrecke
doch statt auf die Umwelt und
naturverträglichere Schiene zu setzen
soll die Bundesstraße die hier auf vier
Spuren erweitert werden ein
Musterbeispiel für gescheiterte
Verkehrspolitik so die Umweltschützer
diese Schienenstrecke die waren früher
mal zweigleisig könnte man ohne Probleme
wieder ausbauen für ein zweites Gleis
elektrifizieren mit einem
halbstunden-tag und dann hätte man eine
wunderbare Alternative die B10 in
Rheinland-Pfalz ist nur ein Beispiel
unter vielen im Bundesverkehrswegeplan
diese Karte zeigt wo überall in
Deutschland Autobahnen und Bundesstraßen
neu und ausgebaut werden sollen
der Bundesverkehrswegeplan umfasst
sämtliche Straßen Schienen und
Wasserprojekte 2016 wurde er vom
Bundestag beschlossen und damals lag mit
fast der Hälfte der Investitionen der
Schwerpunkt klar auf der Straße
mobilitätsforscher Andreas Knie hält den
Bundesverkehrswegeplan deswegen für
veraltet
der Bundes-
und Straßen das heißt wir werden dann
verführt noch mehr zu fahren das können
wir uns angesichts des Klimawandels
nicht mehr leisten deshalb brauchen wir
im Moment ein Stopp für alle Neubauten
der Verkehrsminister besteht dennoch
weiter auf dem Neubau von Autobahnen und
Bundesstraßen und will bestimmte
Ausbauprojekte sogar noch beschleunigen
wir brauchen aber auch den
beschleunigten Ausbau der Straße wenn
wir unseren Wohlstand sichern wollen die
Ergebnisse zeigen eindrücklich dass wir
unsere Ziele eines nachfragegerechten
Verkehrs nicht alleine durch den Ausbau
von Schiene und Wasserstraße erreichen
können wir brauchen dringend
planungsbeschleunigung auch für die
Straße
mobilitätsforscher Knie widerspricht es
werde viel weniger Auto gefahren z.B
blieben Berufstätige lieber im
Homeoffice auch nach Corona
hat sich diese Gesellschaft sehr stark
verändert wir haben herausbekommen mit
den Kollegen von Infos zusammen dass
mehr als 36 Prozent der Beschäftigten an
zwei bis drei Tagen gar nicht mehr ins
Büro gehen das heißt wir haben ein
abnehmende Fahrleistung gerade bei dem
Segment der
Fahrten über 50 km und das heißt wir
brauchen diese Straßen die wir zurzeit
haben nicht mehr in der Zukunft anders
als in deutschland steuert Österreich in
der Verkehrspolitik um
hier investieren sie deutlich mehr in
die Schiene als in die Straße außerdem
gibt es ein landesweites klimaticket zum
Preis von rund 1000 Euro pro Jahr also
drei Euro täglich heißt es damit freie
Fahrt im ganzen Land vom Fernverkehrszug
bis zur Straßenbahn
ich habe jetzt mein Auto aufgegeben
irgendwie diesbezüglich und plane eben
jetzt zu demnächst das klimaticket zu
kaufen ich habe Job gewechselt und und
zusätzlich mache ich jetzt relativ viele
Dienstreisen und damit habe ich das
genommen und und verwende es auch privat
jetzt die Deutsche Bank hat sich nicht
eingeführt hat das Ticket die Klima- und
Verkehrsministerin Leonore gevesla
anders als ihr deutscher Amtskollege hat
sie alle Infrastrukturprojekte gestoppt
und lässt sie prüfen
wir haben ganz viele Projekte das sind
vor 20 30 40 Jahren geplant worden und
die machen mit Blick auf die große
Herausforderung Klimakrise auf die große
Herausforderung biodiversitätskrise
einfach keinen Sinn mehr deshalb kippte
die Ministerin bereits beschlossene
Straßenbauprojekte wie in der Lobau bei
Wien hier sollte ein Tunnel den
Autobahnring um die Hauptstadt schließen
das 2 Milliarden Euro Projekt war lange
geplant und gesetzlich beschlossen der
Autobahntunnel hätte eine enorme
Zerstörung im sensiblen
Naturschutzgebiet bedeutet und passt
nicht mehr in die Klimapolitik
Österreichs die deutsche Verkehrspolitik
beobachtet die Ministerin kritisch
ich kann nur sagen wir haben als
verkehrspolitikerinnen und
Verkehrspolitiker ziemlich historische
Verantwortung derzeit der Verkehr ist
das Klima Sorgenkind Nummer eins auch in
Österreich viele viele Jahre gehen die
Emissionen im Verkehr steil nach oben
anstatt zu sinken und das macht uns auch
Erfolge in anderen Sektoren zunichte und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt die
Entscheidungen treffen die dazu dienen
dass man den Verkehr klimaneutral
bekommen aber eben auch besser machen
für die Menschen in unserem Land eine
Aufgabe auch für den deutschen
Verkehrsminister doch die Realität sieht
bislang anders aus
die Treibhausgasemissionen im Verkehr
stagnieren weitestgehend seit
Jahrzehnten
und in den vergangenen zwei Jahren waren
sie höher als das Klimaschutzgesetz
erlaubt das zeigt die rote Linie in der
Grafik die angibt wie viele Emissionen
das Gesetz im Verkehrssektor zulässt
die Grafik zeigt auch die Emissionen
müssen drastisch sinken sollen die
Vorgaben im Gesetz nicht auch in den
kommenden Jahren gebrochen werden
die Bundesregierung hat sich im
Klimaschutzgesetz dazu verpflichtet
CO2-Emissionen zu verringern gelingt das
auch dem Verkehrsministerium das Gesetz
verpflichtet die Bundesregierung des
Verkehrsministerium aber natürlich auch
den Verkehrsminister dazu diese Vorgaben
diese Klimaschutzvorgaben einzuhalten
das ist nicht passiert wir sehen dort
ein permanenten Rutsch in die
Gesetzeswidrigkeit der muss gestoppt
werden das Verkehrsministerium inklusive
der Hausspitze muss hier arbeiten
das scheint Verkehrsminister Wissing
anders zu sehen seine bisher vorgelegten
Pläne sorgen dafür dass der
Verkehrssektor bis 20 30
Millionen Tonnen CO2 mehr ausstößt als
das Klimaschutzgesetz erlaubt das zeigen
Berechnungen des expertenrates der
Expertenrat für Klimafragen hat das
Ministerium gebeten baldmöglichst
weitere Maßnahmen vorzustellen die eben
die Lücke von 261 Millionen Tonnen bis
2030 schließen kann wir warten darauf
dass eben diese Maßnahmen vorgestellt
werden was bisher allerdings noch nicht
erfolgt ist
das Verkehrsministerium muss also
dringend Nacharbeiten um nicht Gesetz zu
brechen wir fragen nach welche konkreten
Maßnahmen wird das Ministerium in diesem
Jahr auf den Weg bringen um den
CO2-Ausstoß zu reduzieren schriftlich
heißt es Zitat bis zum entkrafttreten
des neuen klimaschutzpakets arbeitet das
bmdv selbstverständlich weiter und der
Hochdruck daran die Klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen
Ausflüchte statt konkreter Maßnahmen im
Pfälzerwald sorgt das für Unmut die
bereits genehmigten Teilstücke an der
B10 werden vorangetrieben und der Wald
muss Weichen für die klimaaktivistinnen
eine Politik von gestern
wir möchten natürlich vor allem das an
die Zukunft an die Jüngeren an die
kommenden Generationen gedacht wird und
das nicht einfach nur weiter wie bisher
gehandelt wird sie kämpfen weiter für
eine Verkehrspolitik die
Klimaschutzziele einhält statt sie zu
brechen